some of the things that we're going to
deal with in congress
this week on afterwards our guest is
david rothkopf author of running the
world the inside story of the national
security council and the architects of
american power
today's guest interviewer is james
bamford author of a pretext for war body
of secrets and the puzzle palace
afterwards is book tv's author interview
program
each week an author on their new book
and each week a different guest
interviewer
[Music]
david as the author of two books on the
national security agency people a lot of
times confuse the nsa with the nsc the
national security council let me just
start off by telling me what the
difference is between nsa and nsc and
what is the national security council
well
there are perhaps three national
security councils the way i look at it
there's the formal national security
council which was
set up in the national security act of
1947 which consists of the president and
the vice president secretary of defense
secretary of state and whoever else they
point to it
if you ask somebody in washington what
they mean by nsc they probably mean the
nsc staff which are the up to 200 people
who work
in the white house or in the old
executive office building who are
essentially the president's personal
staff on international security matters
then there's another nsc which is not
actually official the ad hoc nsc and
that's the president's kitchen cabinet
on these national security issues and
sometimes it includes his wife or people
he went to college with who he trusts
and all three of these
work together to perform the tests that
originally were envisioned for the nsc i
actually wandered around bethesda
maryland which is where i live and
which is near here in washington and
asked people whether they knew what the
nsc was
and uh
about half of them thought i meant the
securities and exchange commission
another group of them thought
it was your nsa the national security
agency a lot of them didn't actually
know what it was at all
it is very confusing to a lot of people
outside the beltway and some people
inside the beltway
and the national security agency is
actually the largest intelligence agency
the agency that actually eavesdrops on
communications around the world and
breaks codes just to
define the difference there
you called the security council national
security council the most powerful
committee in the world what did you mean
by that well the president and his
closest advisors have the ability given
the resources of the united states
government the resources of the united
states to project more force more
quickly to more places in the world than
any other group that's ever existed in
history they also have the ability to
influence economic and political
decisions that are of greater
consequence
than any other country in history has
been able to muster and so as a result
this group many of whom the national
security council staff for instance are
not approved by the senate uh not
overseen by the congress have great
great power
and yet as you indicated they're not
terribly well understood and and i think
that's something that needs to be
addressed
well when it was formed in 1947 it was
uh pretty much just uh to help
coordinate the
uh a coordinating function for the
various national security uh agencies it
didn't have an awful lot of power at
first when did it start acquiring uh uh
enormous amounts of power
well
uh you're right it it didn't have an
awful lot of power at first and and the
reality is that it was formed because
franklin roosevelt for example during
the second world war didn't actually
want to coordinate between his agencies
and in the wake of the second world war
people who'd worked with him said look
if we ever go through this again we
can't afford to go through the same kind
of problems and at the same time they
were creating new agencies in 1947 that
created the defense department and the
cia and the department of the air force
and so forth and so they felt it was
important to systematically bring
everybody together and help give the
president advice harry truman said
you know i'm going to retain the
prerogative this is not going to be a
group that is going to
operate by vote
you will advise me and i will act
dwight eisenhower used it much as he
used his military staffs
and so it didn't really rise up in terms
of the kind of power that it ultimately
took on during the nixon administration
when nixon sat down with kissinger and
plotted things out
as much of the power that accrued to it
came from nixon's own hesitation about
wanting to deal with people as it did
from kissinger's own willingness to
embrace
power
but whatever the reasons what happened
was that
nixon would deal with kissinger
kissinger would deal with the rest of
the government he was the national
security adviser and uh from then on the
nsc has become a kind of begun a kind of
an ascent in power
which has ultimately had it i think
supplant the state department uh and
other agencies as perhaps the most
important uh repository of power in the
entire federal government on these
issues yeah you mentioned that uh with
starting with henry kissinger henry
kissinger has actually been
a model for a lot of people and he's
actually uh you mentioned he's sort of
separated by just one or two degrees of
separation from all the other national
security advisers about 13 of them that
have followed them
well
i i think henry kissinger is the most
influential figure in
modern american foreign policy i think
that's partially due to the power of his
intellect i think it's partially due to
the power of his personality i think
it's partially due to the fact that he
has marketed himself
uh
to the world and has become a kind of a
brand name in and of himself but the
reality was that an entire generation of
members of the foreign policy elite
people from both parties started under
kissinger's wing worked with him during
the vietnam peace negotiations or the
opening of china or a number of the
things that he did and indeed if you
look at every single national security
advisor since kissinger he either worked
with or for kissinger or he worked with
or for somebody who worked with her for
kissinger and uh
you know you see it even today the
national security adviser is steve
hadley who was on kissinger's national
security council staff condoleezza rice
was
mentored by brent scowcroft who was
kissinger's deputy
during the clinton administration tony
lake who was the first national security
adviser was a former aide to kissinger
berger worked with lake so it's a very
very close-knit world
and
these people all know each other
and
big figures like kissinger and
brzezinski
and a number of others have influenced
the entire group
um during the reagan years
the
national security council took on an
even more powerful and dangerous role i
mean the
william casey and who is head of the cia
and oliver north starting using that as
a
sort of a loophole to avoid using the
intelligence agencies that came under a
lot of oversight they began using the
nsc for a lot of secret and very
questionable operations
uh how how did that come about and did
that
have any lasting effect on the
security council yeah i well
first of all i think i would
characterize it
slightly differently i would say that
they became a less powerful and more
dangerous agency
because what happened was reagan
ran against the kissinger model
in fact carter had run against the
kissinger model and said i'm not going
to have anybody like that and then he
brought in big neb brzezinski who very
much stepped into the kissinger model
and ultimately triumphed in the
internecine battles within the carter
administration so after kissinger and
brzezinski were two very large larger
than life figures in this role reagan
said no we're going to go back to a
different approach actually moved the
national security advisor out of the
corner office in the white house demoted
it so that he reported up to ed meese
who was one of the triumvirate of people
who reported to him
and
ultimately this led to a sort of drift
away from the president's supervision of
the nsc and it became a place where
people could freelance and what happened
by the middle of the term when uh
supervision from the president was at
its lowest uh and and a number of the
kind of true believers in the reagan
administration saw a need to address
issues in central america in american
relations with iran which is what led to
iran contra
they did it through the nsc in fact
through the office of
ollie north and
this led to the biggest scandal of the
reagan era in terms of the ongoing
implications for the national security
council
iran contra produced an investigation
the investigation was the tower
commission report uh the tower
commission recommended a kind of
restructuring a re-evaluation of how the
nsc worked and
an effort to make it more systematic and
and and more accountable uh one of the
members of the tower commission was
brent scowcroft who had been national
security adviser uh under ford had been
kissinger's deputy and who later became
national security advisor again the only
person to hold the job twice under
george h.w bush
the lessons
of iran contra guided scowcroft into
inventing essentially what is the modern
national security council uh
interestingly the general counsel for
the tower commission was steve hadley
who's now the national security advisor
let's see uh before we get into the the
more
present day uh uh issues involving the
national security council let me just
get a couple words from you on the on
some of the past uh
national security advisers uh just sort
of your off-the-cuff thoughts on a
couple of these uh uh
zavigne brzezinski uh what about him
well i think brzezinski is
exceptionally intelligent i think he in
many respects is underrated
simply because the carter administration
faced big economic problems at home and
because the iran hostage crisis was such
an attenuated and
frustrating process for everybody but
the carter administration normalized
relations with china
it had the panama canal treaty
and most importantly i think
brzezinski sort of saw the u.s
relationship with the soviet union in a
different way than kissinger had
kissinger and nixon
as you recall pursued daetan which is
kind of like suing for peace it's not a
strategy of strength it's a strategy of
saying let's freeze things here so that
we make sure that our position doesn't
slide
brzezinski had been writing about
soviet entropy and the sort of decline
of the soviet union for many years and
when he came in his policies were based
on the assumption that the soviet union
would continue to decline and the u.s
would rise and it led to something of a
harder line stance on a number of issues
and i think was embraced consciously
subconsciously by the reagan
administration and ultimately became
kind of the approach we used in the end
game with the soviet union this means
that brzezinski really made a lasting
contribution
but you know in in all of his writings
of all of the national security advisors
he's the one who's kind of looked
forward into the future
with the greatest insight
he was talking about the information
revolution before we had a name for the
information revolution and so i have
hold him in very high regard
and how about richard allen
richard allen was a smart guy who who i
think circumstances did not serve well
uh you know he was the young national
security aide to richard nixon in the 68
campaign but was too young to be the
national security adviser and ended up
recommending kissinger who of course
eclipsed him and he never found a place
in there
he came in with reagan
as a national security adviser at a time
when it was
politically appropriate in the position
of of the reagan administration i guess
to devalue the job
so alan was in many respects the least
powerful national security advisor
sort of by the volition of him and the
others in the administration i think it
made it a very frustrating experience
for him and then some minor scandal
issues ended up leading him to leave
office
and uh how about alexander haig
well hague
was never a national security adviser he
was a
secretary of state and a very close aide
to kissinger
who
at the time of allen wanted to assert
the superiority of the department of
state
over the national security adviser he
had sort of lived through what henry had
done and he said well look i'll be
secretary of state but when i'm
secretary of state i'm going to be the
one in charge and the national security
adviser is going to be secondary to me
this led to a lot of tension and of
course
hague famously misspoke uh when reagan
there was an assassination attempt on
reagan said i'm in control here got the
line of succession all wrong uh and you
know he was one of these guys by the way
who who
was a master of a particular kind of
bureaucratic technique which has
probably not gotten enough study and
that is the
dramatic offer of resignation
and
uh you know throughout us history one of
the few sort of levers that cabinet
secretaries have is the ability to go up
to somebody to a president and say well
mr president if you did that i'll be
forced to resign
hague did this fairly regularly and i
think was shocked
when ultimately his offer was accepted
um how about frank carlucci
uh frank carlucci is a very interesting
character uh one of those dedicated
uh government bureaucrats uh who
served in a number of posts
and was then called in uh to become
national security adviser in the wake of
iran contra and part of the reason was
that he had a reputation for propriety
uh and professionalism uh and i think a
well-deserved reputation he had a deputy
colin powell who later succeeded him and
the two of them uh really laid the
groundwork for what scowcroft was later
able to more or less perfect in the in
the bush administration by coming up
with a system where the deputies were
important by briefing the president in
tandem by
trying to be honest brokers within the
system
and
i i think both of them
although they served in the sort of
twilight years of the reagan era
deserve a lot of credit for restoring
an institution that was badly and could
have been fatally damaged
by iran country
uh under um uh clinton uh anthony lake
and then uh samuel berger well tony lake
is another of the national security
advisers who is marked by exceptional
intelligence
um he had worked with kissinger
had been a close aide to kissinger when
he was a young man
ultimately resigned
from kissinger's staff as a result of
the invasion of cambodia
and became alienated from kissinger and
became a vocal and thoughtful critic of
of a number of u.s policies during the
years he was out of office during the
carter administration he was the head of
policy planning in the state department
which is a particularly important role
uh and began to work with berger in that
capacity uh but but tony never had the
uh exceptionally close relationship with
the president that enables a national
security adviser to
really have power the the power of the
national security advisor comes in a
kind of interpersonal transaction from
the president
and
clinton was hesitant on a lot of these
issues
sandy berger had a much closer uh much
longer term relationship with clinton
and by the time that he became national
security adviser four years in he was
able to turn that uh into more power and
the ability to run a a a more
significant nsc operation than in the
first clinton term you know this is a
kind of an interesting point
most
presidential administrations
particularly when the party has been out
of office for a while flounder for a
couple of years because we have a very
strange system in the united states we
fire all the senior people in the
federal government every time an
administration goes out
most other governments don't do this
certainly no company would do it if you
and i were leading a takeover of a
company we wouldn't go in and fire the
entire management team because we'd lose
all the institutional memory but every
time an administration leaves so do the
people who know what's going on uh at
the highest level and you know you saw
this comically with uh bush coming in
and the clinton staff leaving and taking
the w's off the typewriters in in the
white house
this is something that that always
impedes the us government and i think
we'd be better served by having some
core of a permanent career staff in the
midst of the nsc and other operations so
that we didn't lose a year or a year and
a half to the learning curve
uh now just getting to september 11th um
you wrote that it was a catalytic
catalytic event that revealed the core
character of the bush administration's
national security team
it was sort of that point that i guess
the uh
the neocons and the people that were to
the far right uh in the bush
administration really uh
got energized and began going off uh
largely on their own um and you pretty
much indicate that uh the there were two
groups of people the ones that were sort
of the followers of uh scowcroft uh
which conolisa rice was one of them
having been a
sort of student of uh schoolcraft for
quite a while
and then you have the other uh people
sort of the neocons and and their
hangers on and so forth
uh which would be chaney and runsfold
and and
that crowd
uh where was uh uh
what was conolisa rice's uh uh position
in this where she she won uh she came
into office sort of uh with this
background of being a um
sympathizer with skill crop to some
degree and uh she's got to act as sort
of the
referee between these two competing
parties now
well i think
you you characterize it pretty
accurately the
the reality was that the bush
administration was just getting its sea
legs when 9 11 happened
but the event demanded action
president's first response was to turn
to the vice president who had a lot of
experience who had been a secretary of
defense uh and who was playing you know
the sort of senior statesman role within
the administration
uh the vice president in turn had a
really long-standing relationship with
his former boss the secretary of defense
don rumsfeld if you recall in the bush
and the ford administration rumsfeld had
been cheney's boss for a while and so
the two of them
formed a kind of an operating
unit that had disproportionate influence
within uh the councils of the president
meanwhile the president is learning how
to be president he is learning how to be
a foreign policy
analyst and leader himself and the
professor that he has teaching him this
is condoleezza rice and so she is
national security advisor
has you know develops what is probably
the most intimate relationship with the
president of any national security
adviser she spends six seven hours a day
with him she would go to camp david with
him she would go to crawford texas with
him i think they she had her own cabinet
camp david she would have sunday dinners
with the family um and as it was
characterized to me by somebody who's
who's been in the position you know the
the the core choice for a national
security advisor is either staff the
president or run the institution
optimally you try to do both but she was
drawn into staffing the president so
closely that she couldn't really be the
honest broker uh she also you know and
when i interviewed her characterized
herself as the baby of the group and
it's true you know i mean she was
20 years younger
than powell and rumsfeld
she uh was not uh seen as somebody
initially with the kind of gravitas that
they had and so she wasn't really able
to be the broker
and so
powell was left as odd man out
pursuing and advocating kind of
traditional internationalist approaches
she was drawn i think in both directions
and really was focused on serving the
president as loyally as she could uh and
so the balance of power
stayed in the cheney rumsfeld axis and
of course many of the neocons you refer
to worked for one or the other of the
two of them
uh what do you think
skocroff was making of all this his
his student all of a sudden looks like
she's abandoning him basically and
siding with uh with the hard-liners well
i think it was very frustrating
experience for him and he wrote a number
of op-eds that uh infuriated people in
the bush administration because he was
critical of policies in iraq and he was
critical of
unilateralism as a as a mistaken
approach
and i think he had come in thinking look
i'm
one of the closest friends
of the president's father
i am the mentor of the national security
advisor my regime uh was viewed as one
of the most successful they will
probably turn to me i mean i don't want
to get inside his head you know he can
obviously speak for himself but i think
when they drifted in a different
direction and a direction was
inconsistent with the kind of foreign
policy principles that george h.w bush
and and scowcroft and james baker had
pursued
i think he was very frustrated at the
inability
to pull that back i think part of the
frustration came from the fact that his
primary
point of of connection uh
condoleezza rice uh was less powerful in
her ability to manage these things than
he was and that dick cheney had
undergone a kind of a change
many people had throughout his career
seeing dick cheney as kind of the
consummate pragmatic thoughtful
professional
and yet many people uh including those
who had served with him who were
republicans said to me
that they watched him become much more
ideological in the wake of 9 11 and that
this was
a surprise to them
and another reason that the the balance
shifted away from the
traditionalists
um
you can see how the retaliation was uh
taken against skokov for some of his
speaking out he was at the time he was
the head of the piffia the president's
foreign intelligence advisory board
which
uh could have an important uh uh
meaningful um
place in the administration or not
depending on what the president thinks
and for years that have been
in the uh old executive office building
had fairly prestigious quarters there
and then all of a sudden one day it was
moved out to
a less prestigious new eob so
and then
bush decided not to keep him on
after the new administration
um it seems like that was he was sort of
the last voice he empowered
last voices within the administration
for moderation at that point i think at
that point
uh that that's true i think what's
happened is that condoleezza rice's role
has changed
and the closeness that in some respects
undercut her ability to do both sides of
her job as national security adviser
benefits her enormously as secretary of
state
the fact that the current national
security advisor is her former deputy
and actually as you know as i hear it
going over sometimes to meetings
at the state department which is you
know kind of unheard of and in fact
you know if you'd gone to the website of
the nsc six months ago you would have
seen a picture of national security
advisor condoleezza rice but when you go
to the website a month ago the last time
i looked you saw a picture of national
security adviser stephen hadley and
secretary of state condoleezza rice so
you know the power has shifted she's got
a more prominent role and she has been
using that role in a more moderate way
since then
she has blocked a number of neocon
appointments within the state department
she blocked the idea of john bolton
becoming the deputy secretary of state
um but she's been fighting for him to be
ambassador well she's a loyalist you
know she's a loyalist and at the end of
the day when a compromise like that is
reached she's then going to go out and
protect the president first foremost and
you know i i think even if you don't
agree with the policy you have to
respect her for behaving in that way and
i think that was one of the things that
constrained powell
because powell also believes that a
degree of loyalty at least in terms of
republic faces
is is important but i think the bush
administration made a very serious
mistake when it started turning away
descending voices from within
you know that you know it's one thing to
say we will discount the democrats
because they're partisan very often the
democrats are partisan but the way this
system works best
is when the president is presented with
choices and the national security system
that was run by george h.w bush with
baker and wisconcroft or the one run by
nixon
explicitly nixon said i want to be given
choices
i don't want you deciding for me
and and that enables the president to
make informed decisions uh this
president by placing a premium on
loyalty and consensus
robs himself of hearing alternative
views and as we've seen in terms of
things like troop strength and iraq
post
conflict reconstruction in iraq
the rationale for going in the wmd and
the interpretation of the intelligence
under act
and some of the reconstruction of the
government's national security apparatus
he would have been better served
by listening more closely to alternative
views
um
with regard to iraq and the whole
weapons of mass destruction
issue how much of a role did conolisa
rice play in
in that
the national security council while she
was there
um was pushing to get the information on
niger for example the the information
turned out to be phony on whether there
was uranium in niger push to get it into
the president's speech in cincinnati
and uh it was only george tenet who
spoke up against it and finally got him
to take it out but then after tenants
sort of gave up on on that
effort they
they ended up putting it back in the
president's speech
in the state of the union um how much of
a role do con lisa rice have in
pushing that uh that agenda of
putting all virtually everything that
pointed to
there being weapons of mass destruction
uh out there well i think she has to
assume a lot of the responsibility
because at the end of the day the
national security adviser and the nsc
staff are the ones that are putting
words in the president's mouth and it is
their job to determine whether or not
the words are correct whether they'll
have repercussions uh whether they
have been brought from places that seem
to be reliable places ultimately
steve hadley took the wrap
for for this particular misstep
and was rewarded by getting the national
security advisor job afterwards um so uh
i you know it looks to me like he was
publicly taking the rap to avoid
somebody above him taking their app
they deserve responsibility at the end
of the day the person who is responsible
for the way the nsc operates
is the president of the united states
and
if he sends a message about uh the you
know the the kind of processes and the
kind of rigor
uh
that he wants and then that doesn't
serve him
he's really the guy who's got to take
responsibility great thanks we'll be
back in just a minute okay great
afterwards with david rothkopf and james
bamford continues in a moment
house republicans introduced a bill
wednesday to use annual surpluses in the
social security system to finance
individual investment accounts for
workers
los angeles times columnist michael
hiltzek critiques president bush's plan
for the retirement program
in his new book the plot against social
security the politics of retirement
tonight at 7 pm eastern on book tv
hw brands has written on three centuries
of american history from the country's
founding its major turning points and
through the end of the twentieth century
live sunday july third it's your chance
to talk to hw brands in depth
his upcoming book is on the life of
president andrew jackson
in depth with hw brands live sunday july
3rd at noon eastern on book tv on c-span
2.
[Music]
next sunday on afterwards robert mary
president and publisher of congressional
quarterly critiques u.s foreign policy
his new book is sands of empire
missionary zeal american foreign policy
and the hazards of global ambition
he's interviewed by harlan ullman a
senior advisor at the center for
strategic studies and the author of
finishing business 10 steps to defeat
global terror afterwards every sunday at
six and nine pm eastern on book tv
on c-span two
afterwards with david rothkopf and james
bamford continues
you mentioned that uh cheney seemed to
transform after september 11th in the
early stages of the bush administration
from a person who was fairly pragmatic
and didn't really uh have a great
ideological
uh
background on pushing ideological issues
and he seems now to be the leader of the
neoconservative sector of the
the groups and of the of the
administration and pushing as hard as
ever to to go into iraq to
um he's talking about the the wmd issue
when people were
pointing out that there are no wmds out
there and they never found them
what caused this transformation of
cheney from this
pragmatist to the ideologue
well i think
at his core he's very conservative to
begin with
i i think
clearly
911 was as as you noted catalytic uh
because it required action uh and you
know this happens in most
administrations you know if you're
president of the united states or you're
close to the president you will go into
office knowing one thing and that is
that something big is going to happen
that you didn't control
that's going to create a crisis which is
going to test you to the very core and
at the end of the day the rhetoric is
going to fall by the wayside and your
character is going to manifest itself
and i think that that's what happened uh
in the wake of 9 11 with a lot of these
people
having said that you know there are some
trends that are discernible within
cheney during the first gulf war
he was according to people who were
involved in the deliberations one of the
more reluctant about uh going to the
united nations working through uh
building up
the big coalition of allies uh you know
uh fundraising for the the the war
through that coalition he's been
resistant to this kind of process
because i think he believes at a core
level uh
that the president has and deserves a
great deal of prerogative um and is
skeptical of systems that may sta sap
the president of that prerogative
that more than neocon
philosophy is i think what has informed
his views towards the united nations
towards
the nature of the alliances that we've
built up or towards our treatment of
some of our allies
other people within the administration
the paul wolfowitzes and
and some others i think are are truly
neocons in the most uh uh accurate sense
of the word they've thought through the
positions there is a philosophical
grounding for what they're doing uh but
you know we lump people in together uh
the media tends to lump them in together
and you know neocon becomes a code word
in in certain parts of the media for bad
guy uh well some of these neocons truly
believe what they're saying
but they're allied with people like
cheney who are fundamentally
conservative and have certain beliefs
about process that fit with some of
these neocon approaches or people like
rumsfeld
who i think at the end of the day
is neither a neocon
nor
just a conservative but above all else
is a rumsfeldian and seeks to advance
his own self-interest as he defines them
and in so doing has become a powerful
force
in alliance with these other groups
because he is such a a
tough character you know henry kissinger
is quoted in the book as saying
that he found rumsfeld
to be the most ruthless person he'd ever
met you know and that's saying something
uh and
and so i think it is the the confluence
of all of these different characters
at a moment when they needed each other
and where they bound together that's
produced these outcomes now you
mentioned also cheney has the largest
national security staff of any vice
president in u.s history was
larger than john f kennedy's entire
national security council staff at the
time
um
this building of this uh this power
domain within the bush administration
by cheney
how much influence does he have over
bush on these decisions of going to war
in iraq he mentioned that he was the
last person i think you mentioned that
he was the last person to meet with bush
before he actually made the final
decision to go to war
um
is this uh is is
cheyney the driving force behind bush or
is is uh
is this a
partnership or how does that play out
well it's a partnership that's
constantly evolving i don't think
anybody should make the mistake of
underestimating george bush
bill clinton
repeats this constantly to democrats who
often don't listen but but but but
george bush is a formidable character
extremely intelligent guy uh who's got
some deeply held beliefs uh and has
built an administration to help him
pursue them i think in the early years
of the bush administration though he was
clearly not an experienced foreign
policy hand nor was he an experienced
president and he had at his side
somebody who had been secretary of
defense who had been a leading member of
congress who had been a chief of staff
in important republican administration
who his father had a lot of faith in
and naturally he turned to him and
naturally
cheney who's a man of strong views and
strong
impulses
took
the ball and ran with it
and i think cheney during a significant
portion of the first term of the bush
administration actually was kind of the
national security advisor it's not that
his staff did the work of the nsc staff
it's not that there was some inner cabal
it was that he was the 800 pound gorilla
and he had people with
two or three swings at the ball he would
have staff in meetings he would have
deputies in meetings uh his deputy his
chief of staff had the white house rank
equivalent to that of the national
security that's scooter libby right
right and so uh and and he had people in
other parts of the government the john
boltons of this world
or the bill ludys and the doug feis and
other people in the department of
defense who felt that they had sort of
two reporting lines one up to rumsfeld
and one into the vice president's office
and this just gave them disproportionate
influence by the admission of people
very very close to the bush
administration inside the bush
administration and fond of cheney
this the most powerful vice president in
american history
and
i think that is changing a little bit
it's not that he's not still extremely
powerful it's that the president has
five years under his belt that
condoleezza rice has a different kind of
stature than she had before that
rumsfeld who's his biggest ally has been
damaged fairly significantly by a number
of choices that he's made uh and that as
we try to demilitarize u.s foreign
policy the role of the defense
department wanes a little bit and so for
all these reasons cheney
is
still critically important um and and
and and
and a real driving force but he's not
what he was
well the fact that he's uh made so many
blunders in terms of iraq he was
constantly talking about wmd being there
that wasn't there he was constantly
talking about the links between
saddam hussein and al qaeda they were
never there he
was constantly talking about the uh
how successful this would be so uh early
in the in the um
in the war and that turned out not to be
true i mean you would think he'd start
losing some credibility along the way at
some point
um
and uh uh
in terms of rumsfeld i mean the power
balance between rumsfeld and and cheney
where does that come down well you know
i had a
republican insider say to me at one
point that you know he would go to
parties where he'd see rumsfeld and
cheney together and uh and and and he
remarked that you know sometimes
he wasn't sure that cheney remembered
who was working for who uh because
rumsfeld was the boss once and uh
rumsfeld is not a shrinking violet
but they have a very close alliance they
have a very close relationship
cheney's position has certainly
benefited rumsfeld
rumsfeld's
very
sort of canny bureaucratic tactics
and have strength of personality
certainly benefited cheney within the
councils of the administration and the
two of them formed a unique team i think
rumsfeld deserves at least as much of
the credit as cheney for some of those
blunders you were talking about i think
you know that you know the the the
administration has made it i wasn't yeah
i wasn't just uh putting it all on
cheney i agree with you 100 right well
you know and you know you look at the
critical mistakes that the
administration has made
um certainly one of them you know quite
apart from the wmd and rationale for
going into iraq which i consider to be
in some respects smaller because i think
they were planning to go into iraq long
before they got here i think that was
you know that's unfinished business and
that you know you read a lot of remarks
that they made in the campaign and once
they got into office or you talked to
insiders dealing with saddam hussein was
on the agenda long before 9 11. sure it
was uh back in 96 uh the uh fife uh and
uh wilmer and
richard pearl wrote this clean break
memorandum which basically argued
for israel to go into iraq uh that was
96 and then they came up with
this uh uh
argument to clinton to uh basically
declare war on iraq i think it was 98 or
whatever and
that became part of u.s policy although
uh uh not the war part just the uh the
policy of regime change at some time so
i mean the the push has been there right
all through the 90s right and and i
think what they were doing prior to
going into the war was essentially
rationale shopping you know one day
would be wmd the next day it would be
democracy the next day it would be
fighting terrorism you know and it's
like what works and at the end of the
day well uh wolfowitz himself said at
one point that they settled on wmd
because it seemed like that was the
uh the best way to argue for the war
right and the europeans said it i talked
to some european leaders at the time and
they said look the only reason we're
going to support this is wmd and so it
was like okay well if that's going to
work we'll make it work but apart from
that decision i think the seminal
mistake of the bush administration so
far has been not sending enough troops
into iraq the decision and it's not like
the information wasn't there it's not
like they didn't have the intelligence
to know they needed more it's not like
precedent didn't say they needed more
it's not like the army chief of staff
general shinseki wasn't saying we needed
more
or the state department wasn't laying
out a clear plan for what was needed on
reconstruction
rumsfeld
arrogantly
essentially said no we don't because
that was part of his original uh plan on
coming into the pentagon to reorganize
it to downsize it to focus more on the
technology and so forth right and people
didn't don't realize now or don't
remember very well right now that he was
almost on the way out when september
11th came up right he was the most
likely guy to leave town early because
transformation wasn't going well and he
had alienated the military brass to such
a huge extent but you know you know
while the technological transformation
that he talked about has a lot of appeal
and a lot of value in certain kind of
war
when you're stabilizing a country it's
boots on the ground
and there is nothing else that can make
the kind of difference as as as as
soldiers
moving around door to door and if you
don't have enough soldiers you can't
contain the problem now
i think there are a lot of reasonable
cases to be made that uh you know iraq
is so fragmented uh that
it it might be impossible to contain the
problem anyway
but certainly going in under strength
is represents a deliberate decision to
unlearn many of the lessons of the
recent past and
and that decision lies heavily on the
doorstep of rumsfeld with the
collaboration of cheney
and
the background a lot of these people as
you mentioned rumsfeld's not really a
neocon he's a pragmatist who
has been pushing for years for the u.s
to expand militarily around the world
but he's not really an ideologue
but rumsfold and cheney and and all the
rest they um
and a lot of the neocons that were both
inside and outside the administration
were arguing at the very beginning that
this was going to be a very easy war
cakewalk used to be talked about how the
iraqis would come out with
flags and
um
it'd be sort of like
you know the the allies in paris in 1945
and so forth so
um that completely was uh uh wrong and
um
part of the reason i think uh and i
don't know what your view is but these
are people that spent most of their
careers in in office jobs or in
think tanks and so forth none of them
served in the military a number of them
disdained the military when like cheney
when he was
during the vietnam period
and all of a sudden they're faced with a
real war and it's not going the way that
they have planned it well they also you
know they didn't listen
to the people with the military
experience the united states military
has at his leadership level some of the
most remarkable people in washington
some of the most experienced and
intelligent people in washington and
they were deliberately being turned off
but i think you know it goes beyond that
i think they overreacted to 9 11 in some
fundamental ways this led to decisions
to violate not just military doctrine
but principles that are core principles
that have led to american strength in
the world and you know when
guantanamo was set up i have a friend
who is down there who got a memo from
the department of defense signed by the
secretary of defense saying you have
more latitude than you
uh traditionally would have had while
you are
interrogating these prisoners
and abu ghraib is another example of
that and i think you know compromising
america's moral authority
just like compromising our economic
strength
reveals a deep misreading of the nature
of national security policy national
security policy is not about identifying
threats and responding to them national
security policy needs to be about
identifying sources of our strength and
cultivating them and then using those
sources of our strength in order to
uh help us protect against threats and
that's how we won the cold war not
containment but you know as you know
george kennan writing in the long
telegram in you know in 1947
said
if we are to defeat the soviets it will
be by cultivating a strong economy and a
strong society because that will enable
us to do what we want to do and it will
draw people towards us and these guys in
their desire to make a mark to react
essentially
undercut the two pillars of our strength
our our economic strength and our moral
authority or our political strength
uh exactly and i agree 100 that
i think the key thing is to show an
example to the world that we should be
something to be admired to be looked up
to and that will cause populations
around the world to want to be a
democracy but right now when uh when you
have a lot of the world seeing uh you
know the the ultimate and dirty laundry
being hung up uh avograve and guantanamo
and so forth it's having the opposite
effect uh just this week there was a
report in the washington post or the the
new york times rather
i said iraq may be prime place for
training of militants uh cia report
concludes
um so what we're creating is not uh
a safer world we're creating a more
dangerous world we're creating a
haven for terrorists to learn their
trade
to find better ways to blow up cars to
blow up buildings and
i think that was the reaction of the
public
when they did a poll that the
public came out saying that they feel
the
um the war in iraq is making the world a
more dangerous place now does this have
any effect on on the people uh in the uh
national security council and the the
inner workings of the bush
administration and bush himself or or
does this
sort of
roll off their backs like rain well i
don't think it's rolled off their backs
like rain i you know i i i think that
you can see in the first six months of
the second term
with the sort of charm offensive
globally
where you know condoleezza rice and
laura bush have made more trips
internationally
by far than donald rumsfeld or dick
cheney
that we're trying to offer a new face to
the world uh i think that you know the
the effort to emphasize africa in the
upcoming g8 talks is a desire to show
look we have a conscience and we can
reach out
to the rest of the world
but i think a lot of chickens are going
to come home to roost in the next few
months whether it's the iraqi referendum
uh or the progress of insurgency against
the united states or the elections uh in
the palestinian territories and whether
hamas actually wins those elections
and also i might add
how the u.s economy fares when we seem
to not care about building up deficits
and spending money on war
despite the fact that borrowing that
money from the few countries in asia
that are willing to lend us that money
puts us in a very very precarious
position uh right down to main street
you know interest rates go up
people can't pay their mortgages
housing bubbles pop
the economy suffers and our national
security suffers you know all of these
things are connected and i think we have
made as many mistakes of commission
as we have of omission well one of the
problems i think uh all along has been
the the lack of attention that the
public was paying to this uh this war
and a lot of the things that we were
doing it seemed to be um and the press
to large degree was putting it on the
back back pages um only now they're
starting to um
really get uh people's attention the
polls are starting to drop
i've always thought that uh one of the
the problems is that uh
the public hasn't has very little
invested in this war
it's all uh people who are volunteers
there's no draft
and they're not paying anything and
their taxes for it their taxes are
supposedly being lowered
and one way to avoid these
wars in the future i think wars that may
eventually generate into
attacks in syria or iran or wherever is
to uh
have a draft and
no deficit spending on um on a war you
pay for that war that year as a
surcharge of your income tax then i
think people would start paying a little
bit more attention to
whether we're going to a war for a good
reason or a bad reason well i think
that's true i think that people don't
feel the pain except for the ones who
are closest to the war
i think we've moved away from the
constitutional ideal of the congress
approving movements to war because we
characterize things somewhat differently
we leave the decision with the executive
branch and i also think in the wake of 9
11 what happened in the united states
was that if you were to oppose this
action you were equated with becoming
traitorous that you were not patriotic
you were not supporting the united
states debate was quashed at just the
moment we needed the most debate now i
personally think there are plenty of
reasons to go into iraq uh i i i think
the time was not right
i think the rationale was not right i
think the method was not right but i
think iraq was a bad place and certainly
saddam was a bad guy i think there are
plenty of reasons for us to intervene
even unilaterally when we see a dramatic
threat to the united states an imminent
threat and that's been u.s policy for a
long time what i see as the principal
problem however is stepping away from
the ideals that were framed in the
earliest days of the republic and
reinforced after the second world war
which is that whatever power is accrued
by individuals or states needs to be
submitted to a system of law because
that's essentially what we're about
george washington could have been king
he chose not to be he said that's not
why we fought i will submit myself to
the system of law i will leave office
voluntarily i no man is above the system
at the end of the second world war we
said although we are the last great
surviving power we are
untouched by the war 50 of world trade
passes through our border
we will create a global system that we
will participate in because we realize
what happens when nation states act
alone in their narrow national interests
and these principles were completely
abrogated in the wake of 9 11
because we assessed the threat as being
so great
that
working within systems building
communities building up systems of law
was no longer in our interests and i
think that that played into the hands of
the terrorists i think it weakened us
and and i think that that is the
essential change that needs to take
place over the course of the years to
come is that we need to again convince
the world
and believe in our own hearts that it's
on our interest to have a system of law
where our interests are protected but so
are everyone else's
well it seemed to be uh
an issue back uh when we were going into
war was uh the question of whether wmd
actually existed in in iraq and
uh people uh you know if you look back
at the uh that period of time we had
more intelligence people on the ground
in iraq there than anyplace else in the
world at that point they were going all
over looking
for wmd
and uh what i think people seem to
to
fail to
think about was the
the push to get those inspectors out
there to put the the troops in there
which is the complete reverse of what
you want to do if you're an intelligence
officer you want to keep the
intelligence people there on the ground
as long as possible collecting
intelligence and finding out what's
going on
and not pull them out and and put the
troops in uh and
that was whether you wanted the war or
not that was a huge blunder i think well
i think that's right and i think you
know the 911 commission said
uh that the nsc
uh was virtually dysfunctional in the
run up to 911 with regard to how it was
using intelligence and how it was coming
up the system i think that the changes
we've made in the intelligent system
since 911 are also very revealing you
know the national security act of 1947
created the director of central
intelligence so you had a central figure
to coordinate all the intelligence
agencies it didn't work because the
president didn't empower that figure to
do what he was supposed to do so what
was the solution
create another one put in another layer
there's no business in the world that
would respond to a failure of management
by creating a new layer of management
because that only makes it harder to
coordinate and furthermore the place
where we really needed intelligence
reform was on capitol hill where you
need to change the process of
authorization appropriation of funds
which is what creates the stovepipes and
those stove pipes create the
institutional separations that make
communications very difficult and we
didn't do that so again we've sort of
paid lip service to the notion of
creating a more effective intelligence
apparatus but we haven't done the steps
that are necessary to actually address
the problems that exist within it so i
wouldn't expect that you're going to see
it work better in the future until we're
really willing to tackle some of these
harder issues so you see the the new
director of national intelligence more
or less just as a sort of redundant
additional layer in the intelligence
community well i think that's what it's
amounting to now i mean the director of
national intelligence does the daily
briefing for the president instead of
the cia director the director of
national intelligence handles the budget
process instead of the cia director the
director of national intelligence is
building a bureaucracy of a thousand
people around him
which is not exactly going to speed
communications nor without these changes
that we've talked about is it going to
deal with the cultural issues of
integration of jointness we need on the
civilian side of the government the kind
of jointness
in interagency operations where people
in the fbi have to work in the cia and
people in the cia have to work in the
treasury or the state department and so
forth like you have on the military side
in order to get the system to work but
when that happened in the military side
through goldwater nickels in the late
80s it was because
you couldn't be promoted they they made
it so that it was critical to your
career path in order to promote that
jointness until we get that kind of
incentive system in place
you're not going to solve this problem
within the intel side or between the
intel side and the crime fighting side
or among all the civilian agencies
uh in the couple of minutes we have left
uh
what's your view on the uh the downing
street memos a
number of people in the press put it at
first and uh they were very slow in in
uh
and actually uh commenting or doing
stories on it and um
a number of other people think that
they're in essence
a smoking gun or equivalent to something
like the pentagon papers or whatever and
again these memos one of the key things
the memos show is that there was a
um
an effort according to the
head of british intelligence who was
attending a meeting in washington um
to
wrap the uh intelligence around the
policy rather than the other other way
around
which is not the way to do business
it's not the way to do business you know
i i you know i have the reaction of the
downing street memo of uh
uh you know
claude raines and casablanca you know
i'm shocked shocked you know i mean
everybody knows this
everybody knows that the administration
had this agenda everybody knows they
were rational shopping everybody knows
they shaped
some of the intelligence to support
their
conclusions
i think we need to be intellectually
honest though
this is not the first administration to
do this you're one of the great students
of intelligence out there and
administrations do it regularly i saw it
happen in the clinton administration
intelligence would come in saying you
know aristide was a bad guy and people
would immediately you know put their
hands over their ears and they say oh we
don't want to hear that because that's
not consistent with our policy the
difference here though is we have people
dying every day over in iraq based on
that i i agree that there is an enormous
issue of degree but
and and i'm not excusing it i'm merely
saying this happens all the time
you know at the end of the day you elect
people because you think they're going
to use the intelligence properly and
we have not created a big penalty for
these people in using the intelligence
improperly and until it sort of
resonates to the electorate and they say
no sorry we're not doing that uh
it'll happen again
thanks very much dave it was a pleasure
talking to you and uh enjoyed reading
your book thank you thank you very much
i appreciate it
next sunday on afterwards robert mary
president and publisher of congressional
quarterly critiques u.s foreign policy